Nickelodeon's Doug is still a major
source of nostalgia for early
Millennials who grew up in the splat TV
era The Diary style cartoon series
centered on the life of a boy in
small-town bluffington as he grappled
with the typical issues of youth from
navigating an unrequited infatuation to
concealing a superhero alter ego Doug
funnies life was both relatable and
charming to watch but what you may not
know about the series is how it became
so beloved in the first place and how it
hit a few major speed bumps along the
way here's a look back at some of the
things you might not know about Doug the
life of Brian it's hard to imagine Doug
as being about anyone except well Doug
but creator Jim Jenkins originally had
another name in mind
in 2012 Jenkins told split cider that
since the character was supposed to be a
very any guy look he wanted to name him
something completely blase Jenkins
explained at the beginning I was calling
him Brian it was sort of just a generic
name I thought that Doug had that
feeling and that sound about it it was a
conscious choice because I wanted him to
be this very neutral middle-of-the-road
guy Doug's middle name Yancey also had
some significance for Jenkins as it was
shared by his own grandfather
Doug's embarrassment over it stemmed
from a very real place as he had a
childhood friend who also hated his own
name growing up much to Jenkins
amusement ad man Jenkins Doug doodles
originally existed as a sort of
alter-ego for the artist who said he
desperately needed an outlet from the
real world where problems are a lot more
complicated than they are for the
residents of his pseudo utopia
bluffington Jenkins once explained of
the character's origin I like to doodle
and Doug was just one of those guys that
kept doodling over and over mercial
Watchers might even remember a very
early version of Doug bouncing around on
a pogo stick in his signature vest for a
1989 Florida grapefruit juice commercial
and he and his prized pooch porkchop
were later seen in 1990 USA Network
commercial bluffington is real
eventually Jenkins collected his
drawings into a book called Doug got a
new pair of shoes and sent a copy to a
Nickelodeon executive which led to the
network ordering an eight-minute pilot
episode called Doug Kent
Jenkins immediately went to work
creating his own production studio to
make it happen as he began developing
other characters for the series
Jenkins again drew inspiration from his
own life and the people he knew it's
kind of like how I remember childhood
Doug's love interest Patti mayonnaise
for example was based on Jenkins own
childhood crush supporting characters
Roger Klotz and Doug's best friend
Skeeter Valentine were also based on
people Jenkins grew up with no
instruments needed you probably know
that mega famous voice actor Billy West
also known for voicing the title
characters for Nickelodeon's popular
cartoon series the Ren & Stimpy show was
cast to portray Doug who's a painfully
shy 11 and a half year old
however West wasn't the only voice actor
to make a major impact on the show actor
Fred Newman was brought on to voice some
of the zanier sounding characters
including porkchop Skeeter and mr. dink
whatever
I'm dink bud dink you can call me mr.
dink Newman even ended up creating that
earworm of a theme song using the
simplest of tools of that catchy intro
Newman explained that wasn't Doug's
voice that was actually my voice we
wanted to use as much as we could
household objects things that a kid
could have make it sound too innocent
that's right Newman relied on his unique
beatboxing and honking skills to create
a lot of the sounds heard throughout the
catchy intro
[Music]
the rainbow rebuke the title character
of Doug and his family were drawn to be
very obviously Caucasian but many other
characters in the series boasted rather
unusual skin colors from skeeters teal
complexion to Rodgers lime-green tone to
Beebe Bluffs purplish appearance however
Jenkins insists he wasn't trying to make
any major socio-political statements
with his colorful cast of characters
Jenkins told huff posts of the
controversy over his main character
skintone people are certain that Skeeter
is an african-american guy I'm like well
he's blue if that's how you see him
that's great it's not a bad thing but I
never planned it Skeeter is blue and
he's Doug's friend a networked angle
following its original 52 episode run
from 1991 to 1994 Nickelodeon declined
an option to renew Doug for a new season
despite Jenkins being signed for 65
episodes the decision which reportedly
came as a shock was based upon some
budget tightening underway at
Nickelodeon
however Nickelodeon's voluntary loss was
Disney's gain as it allowed the House of
mouse to scoop up the production rights
and studio for Doug and proceed with
carrying the hit show forward the show
was retooled as brand spanking new Doug
as part of the ABC Saturday morning
cartoon lineup for three additional
seasons and spawned a live-action
musical a line of toy merchandise with
fast-food cross-marketing and even a
film called Doug's first movie uh not so
happy ending the saga of Doug funnie and
Patti mayonnaise never quite came to a
close
leaving fans to wonder whether the green
vested gentlemen managed to win Patti's
heart for the long haul according to
Jenkins the answer is likely no he told
Entertainment Weekly that he couldn't
picture the two ending up together as
adults because it's just not realistic
saying most people don't end up with
their first love perhaps Jenkins is
merely jaded based on his own experience
later in life with the real-life person
who inspired Patti in a Nick animation
podcast he recounted his reunion with a
woman in question and admitted that they
didn't enjoy some sudden romance
despite his hopes that it might happen
after she reached out to invite him to
dinner Jenkins admitted to wondering if
something might spark until she said oh
oh I want you to meet my husband sorry
ugh